hi I'm Andrew Frank and if you're a
comedian or anybody interested in comedy
this is a thing to listen to that is
lovely and informative and joel's
awesome you're official yeah you now
have your own hot breath water that's
great
it's pontus water the coolest coolest
water for the hottest podcast Blue Ridge
Mountains spring water from Georgia very
nice so this is it like it actually
started this is the podcast nobody it
started yes but to do your intro okay
and then we're gonna kick this off cool
are you nervous no excited yeah I'm
excited okay good yeah yeah you just you
just won a round of World Series of
comedy so I feel like you're gonna be in
a good place
yeah that's great yes all right here we
go
hot breath averse welcome back to the
hot breath podcast your weekly guide to
comedy mastery I am your host comedian
Joel Byers
let's did I just sit a little bit I
didn't like me sitting in front of the I
like the tree in the middle between the
palm tree but then I just probably for
Jerry's interview I was probably sitting
lopsided and guess how much it matters
zero no one's gonna be like oh great
interview but the host was sitting right
in front of that tree and it just ruined
it for me or the host interrupted his
intro to reframe the shot so this is the
hot breath podcast your weekly guide to
comedy mastery I am your host comedian
Joel Byers and today's guest hot
brethren and sistren
this is a cat I met here in st. Louis at
the world series of comedy I don't
always do this with the show where I
meet someone and I'm like you got to do
this show but I saw him on stage blown
away by the material but what blew me
away even more was in looking into his
origin story of starting comedy at 14
working at a local club here the funny
bone and just studying comedy a real
student of the craft and his DIY
approach to comedy he is toured around
the world with his comedy he's created
his own tours beyond just like I have a
booking agent whatever know this guy's
bootstrapped every opportunity he's
gotten all the way to most recently the
Edinburgh Fringe Festival and several in
Vancouver as well Vancouver friendships
yeah Vancouver Fringe so this is a
comedian who his work ethic you're gonna
learn a lot about and how you can create
your own success but also we went around
the st. Louis scene here where he
started and then he went to Chicago and
now lives in Seattle
but in seeing how the community of st.
Louis reacted and seeing him even we
went to an open mic and it was a full
list he didn't do a spot but he vouched
for me to get up and do a spot that just
shows in the comedy world the respect
that this cat has in comedy so there's a
lot to learn from the craft side but
also in just how to be a comedian that
people actually want to work with so
with all that being said welcome to the
hot breath averse Andrew Frank everyone
Andrew Frank you made it yeah thanks man
thanks for having me I'm so excited
about this because in us hanging out
randomly we randomly did a show in
Chicago a few years ago we randomly run
into each other here and you're like
yeah we did it we did a show at
Hamburger Mary's you know that I think
it's a it's like a drag bar yeah I think
they do like I don't know what the the
PC term is but great we have someone
walk in to hear me say that triggered
sorry but long story short we do a
random show together now we randomly run
into each other and getting to go around
to the comedy scene and getting hang out
with you
just like we got to get him on here you
you seem to be very self-aware
and you seem to have a motivation behind
your comedy that I think comedians can
really learn from are you aware of this
are you intentional about this yeah
absolutely but can you tell me what you
think the motivation is and then we'll
see if it's okay well it I was gonna say
pure that's a little vague I think the
motivation is you just you want to
create good memorable comedy beyond just
like a lot of people do comedy right now
because it's the cool thing to do yeah
you actually want to have a message
behind what you're doing yeah I guess
there's a message in everything but I
definitely wanna create the comedy that
I want to see comedy really influenced
the way I thought about the world as a
young person and I know what it feels
like to be young and to be introduced to
new ideas through art and I wanted to I
want to be that for more people you know
because comedy sort of serves as as a
very positive way to explore ideas that
are contradictory to the ones that you
hold but you actually end up feeling
good when you resolve those paradoxes
you know because it's very frightening
too if you raised a certain way if
you're taught certain things it's it can
be frightening to go out and learn other
things or try other experiences and
comedy happens to create dopamine and
good stuff that helps you yeah explore
the things that you're afraid of
that's what Jerry was saying in the
interview we just did was that he
talking laughter triggers the same like
impact that like falling in love does it
affects their brain the same way but
you're thinking I love is scary too is
scary especially if you bomb at it yeah
what is let him a little know a little
bit about your background sure as well
cuz that that's an interesting context
for your comedy yeah I am I started very
young at 14 14 was my first official
stand-up set at my freshman year high
school talent show at a fundamentalist
Christian school did a 10-minute set for
the talent show and ever since then I
fell in love with it and started going
to this coffeehouse that was right by my
house st. Charles coffee house is no
longer existing but
a ton of high-school kids went there
they're all poets and musicians and
there was one other comedian and would
go there every Tuesday and Thursday and
dude you know 10 15 minutes sets and it
was really cool to perform in front of
our peers then I started going to the
club but yeah my my dad is a pastor grew
up in the church and I got up on stage
in the church quite a bit especially at
church camp that was like priests and up
like ages 11 12 13
hmm every summer camp I would get in
front of the whole congregation and do
five minutes of stories and stuff and
then I that I was addicted to that and I
just wanted that's why I wanted to go
back to camp every years to do that and
then I basically was oh and then like
this is there was there was a comedian a
Christian comedian
Tim Hawkins he does like parody
Christian songs he's like a Christian
Weird Al essentially he grew up with my
basketball coaches and so the fact that
I knew like that I the fact that I knew
a guy who had a job as a comedian and
he's very very successful very do you
know him yeah I'm familiar with them
yeah the fact that I knew a guy that was
doing this as a profession that
something clicked when I was young that
oh this is a way that you can be this is
a lifestyle mm-hmm so it's possible yeah
what I mean you grew up like strictly
religious I mean there's I mean you talk
about your comedy but what is the
reaction to I'm 14 I want to do stand-up
now like what is your parents rap I
don't think they really understood what
it meant I don't know if they do now
yeah you just don't think they knew well
what is what was that decision how did
you decide okay I'm going to go do
comedy at this talent show I don't know
I mean it was a very small school and I
was lucky in the sense that I got small
Mayon graduating class was maybe 40 and
we were the smallest class in the school
so I would say 400 kids total seventh
grade through twelfth grade and I went
to school with these kids
ever since second grade was the same
kids in the whole class for that whole
time and yeah so it was a very small
school so I was able to do everything
able to do sports and theater and so
know the town show was happening and I
really wanted to do it so and the year
before I had done an impression of our
soccer coach Hannibal in a jar
he is from trinidad and tobago so i went
up on stage and did a like a 10 minute
routine of him in eighth grade yeah and
then I and then I decided I would rather
speak from my perspective than to do a
character do you remember like your
first jokes yeah
any you think worth repeating here
no is it all religion based cuz you're
in there's a lot about the school my mom
was the guidance counselor at the school
Dickens
so yeah there's always been like a
little bit of a rebellion against
Authority and but it's but everyone like
yeah I would make fun of the structure
of the school and everyone knew my mom
so I could make fun of my mom and same
with my dad at my church you know get on
stage and make jokes so yeah it it puts
you in a unique position when you're
when your parents are authority figures
for other kids yeah you know I mean yeah
yeah
I will I mean in middle school my
stepdad was the principal oh yeah
and he is the worst yeah it's terrible
my my wife's mom was the counselor of
her high school as well I understand
that dynamic and what it's like to be a
teenager but then your parent is like an
authority figure around your friends
yeah it's annoying yeah so I think
comedy has always been away all
throughout history to challenge
authority yeah challenge illegitimate
Authority so the stuff that really works
and well it's it's like Anarchy right if
something is unnecessary and you point
to it through a joke the cracks become
evident right so and then when did you
start working at the funny bone I would
say Javan teen maybe 17 yeah okay and
your parents were just cool like was
there any resistance because and I'm
reiterating this this point because I
feel like a lot of comedians are you so
like you kind of say there's like
anarchy and a lot of friends and family
don't understand the path and I feel
very fortunate I have always my parents
were never like what do you mean you
want to be a commune they're always like
oh yeah we always knew
like you were on that path it just took
you realizing it like for you was there
any resistance you had to overcome in
making this like your lifelong pursuit
with like parents questioning it or
anything hmm
I think they questioned it but they're
also they're very supportive in the
sense that they basically told me and my
sister that we could do I don't know we
were both very ambitious kids we both
had dreams and we both went out and made
them true so they must have done
something right I know they they were
supportive okay so no one was like are
you sure
or you should you should go to school or
there's always been a little bit of that
but they know my personality so they
know that it wouldn't work if they tried
to tell you not to yeah I was gonna do
it anyway so you might as well just they
might as well just say it's okay
contrarian okay yeah and now how do they
feel about your material because your
material is like oh and and when you say
fundamentally should we just ask them to
come the interview I just you know what
I why I want you on here is because
you're like you're like in the trenches
so I feel like a lot of listeners so if
I interview Jerry Corley mm-hmm you know
he's been doing comedy 30 years he's
kind of on the other side of the
trenches in a sense you're in the middle
of this in the middle and doing it
yourself so I'm hoping that a lot of
listeners will to align with a lot of
the struggles absolutely you're going
through but that maybe you've overcome
as well yeah so that's why I'm getting
into the weeds on like the process of
becoming a comedian
you know yeah I mean it's a very
complicated answer in short it would be
that they definitely disagree with the
material okay the idea is contained in
the material I think they admire my
approach to comedy or at least the the
work ethic or yeah the fact that I take
it so seriously and have put so much
into it so they admire that so I'll say
that but and then like career why what
no nothing
career career-wise I think I think it
would
just thinking from their position it
would be very hard to be a parent and to
have your child have a life path that is
this ambiguous so there's some objective
tangible things about the progression of
a comedy career but it's not nearly as
laid out as a lot of other careers and a
lot of other work you know there isn't
there isn't like a surefire plan of
steps that you can do too and then and
it's so open-ended that's what that's
what I love about art is that it's like
you can keep growing and keep your
definition of success and all these
things continues to evolve but it may be
hard for someone else to under
understand who's not in it you know and
doesn't see the work on a daily basis
you know yeah are you cool with your or
your parents are you cool with your
parents it almost sounds like you're
like I'll say that and then move on like
are you guys on speaking terms
yeah we speak yeah but that's like a big
better but there's like there's kind of
a rift right now because you're pursuing
comedy I don't know it could be a lot of
things and you're not alone and like I'm
not trying to make you corner you right
now
I actually didn't it's just an
interesting path we're starting to lead
down I didn't intend her to but you're
not alone in if we're gonna use comedy
as the backdrop of like this is what I
love this what I was born to do and like
the people that I love and respect
aren't don't can't seem to like jive
with this if that makes sense so is that
kind of where you are you're 26 you said
right so is that kind of a the kind of
Kruk sure and right it's a good summary
yeah okay but there's a lot of time and
a lot of life to live so I think I think
well my parents and I we'll both learn
how to more effectively communicate who
we are and the way we see the world you
know mm-hmm yeah it's interesting I mean
like I'm and I'm not even doing this for
a bit I think there's a big difference
between the way we and my parents and I
interpret art where it's like they have
a literal interpretation of the Bible
right
whereas I see the Bible as
the work of people over you know
millennia constructing myths
collectively and there's so much rich
meaning and truth in them just like any
artistic endeavor so I view it
artistically but they view it literally
so yeah I do think there's different
levels of interpretive skills where
where they could see my act and not
really know how to interpret it you know
because yeah does that make sense kind
of so did they come to a show and then
we're like oh dear
they're like excited our son's pursuing
comedy and then because he's been doing
it at camp and all this and then they're
like oh but he's talking about very
contrarian approaches to how you were
raised
you know yeah they've come but we've
never had any in-depth discussions about
the content of the oh oh the material
it's almost just like a silent
understanding yeah oh okay yeah it's
what I looked when I look for when I
watch a comedian is like how much am i
learning about this comedian like what
are they doing material that no one else
could do and when I saw you do your set
I was like wow he only did seven minutes
and I learned so much not only about
where you come from but your mindset
your philosophical approach to life and
at so I think so how long have you been
doing comedy like you did it first time
fourteen but how long would you say
you've actually been like grinding at it
I mean yeah ever since that first one I
ever since fourteen you were on stage a
lot yeah oh I went to that coffee house
and was doing you know two to 15-minute
sets a week o term age fourteen on you
know oh that's so it definitely has
increased over the years but twelve
years really yeah Wow okay okay well
that makes a little more sense that
you've been sharpening the sword to be
able to say so much about yourself your
beliefs and also your personal life in a
seven minute said I was like that's
we're at nine and a half years in a
comedy I want to be doing more things
like that sure what was your process
getting that self-revealing on stage if
you will I think I was always like that
and in person I guess comedy was always
the way I'd like revealed things about
myself to my friends and the people
around me it's just a good way to like
figure out like okay I may have some
subversive or contrarian thoughts to the
community I was raised in and so a joke
is a good way to like figure out oh did
the other people also think this you
know and is it okay and so yeah I got
very good at that and very interested in
that because comedy yeah reveal some
things that we may not explicitly say
aloud you know yeah and but what is cool
your sister is she cool she's cool like
how many and what does she do she's a
teacher
cuz you said you both found your
passions and pursue it yes so that's
cool and you're you're like a teacher on
stage as well but is that that is
intentional you being kind of like
you'reyou're saying funny things but
you're also like I want them to leave
with something sure well I think that's
just a matter of sort of like
intellectual responsibility where if
you're going to be on a stage if you're
going to be talking into a microphone in
front of a bunch of people you better
have some good things to say you know
what I mean like you're up there so
that's that's what I definitely desire
when I go see things when I go see a
film when I see a book when I see a book
look at a book yeah I definitely like
I'm interested in the ideas so and
stand-ups this really cool thing because
it's your and you're in charge of
yourself and so you can you can layer
the act as much as you possibly want
with the ideas that you think are
important and funny so I try to put
those all together to see what they do
to people's brains how do you put your
jokes together they're very complex
where do they start and how do they
evolve I guess it just starts with one
observation and then you make
connections between things so you see
one little one little thing that's funny
and then it's sort of like thematically
connected to things or one thing I love
to do is juxtaposed information that
isn't
traditionally related and then you find
a way to put it together so you sort of
Ram ideas together mm-hmm
because yeah the imagination and all all
of life is connected so the either you
can always find some way to connect
something that's happening in the world
or something that you're thinking it's
just a matter of recreating those the
steps to connect them you know and
that's often
yeah that's out of them the brain
delights in that when we put things
together
you know how do you find the connections
what's your process do you sit down and
like make lists or when you see two
things see that juxtaposition now what
next what's the next step well then you
bring it to the stage and you see what
makes people laugh and then I sort of
like it's kind of like the scientific
method where you try to recreate results
right so it's an experiment each time
and then like you figure out the which
variables stay constant and then and
there's they're always going to
fluctuate a little bit but you find
exactly like where people connect the
dots you find out where you get
responses and then you're able to build
upon those responses and you can
reiterate what made them laugh the first
time you say things in a different way
are you like once you find the the entry
point then you can multiply the laughs
based on you know based on their
responses you know but I yeah I bring
ideas to the stage and I look for the
openings I look for I really really
listen to to people when they're having
the Epiphany and then you go okay now
now I know where it erupts now I can
recreate it better you know and in a
more complex way you do it more onstage
than like on page oh yeah absolutely
oh so you don't even you're not like
here's a juxtaposition let me write yes
I'm jealous of things but I okay and
sometimes I'll write long-form but
because stand-up is a verb like a verbal
art form I try to have loose ideas that
I bring to the stage and then you've
through repetition then I can write them
down but it's very hard to to write
things that truly mimic human speech you
know yeah so yeah we write it's almost
like what we write sounds different than
how we
talk I know mark Normand said on here
that his writing process is for an hour
every day he just talks about topics
about jokes he's working on but he'll
just talk out loud like a madman for an
hour and that's how he writes cuz it's
like verbally writing you know he just
rep reps his jokes out loud and that's
how it comes off so natural mmm true to
his voice mmm absolutely yeah and it's
very it's very hard when you're sitting
with a piece of paper no matter how much
you've been onstage it's very hard to
have that a truly accurate hypothetical
crowd in your head you know really helps
to have the social pressure of
presenting these ideas in front of
people it kicks it into gear you know
you got to figure out what you're trying
to say how to say it yeah being observed
is a huge part of creativity for me you
know being observed being observed yeah
what do you mean by that that you have
all there's all of this going on inside
of you uh-huh and yeah I guess it's just
that attention sort of provokes what's
inside of you and you find a way to get
it out to people you know or it's like a
it's a desire to convey what's what's
really in here but you can't really do
alone you need to be seen you need to be
understood I don't know you do yeah but
that's it yeah yeah okay so you're like
driving on a point then you're like yeah
but I don't know a lot of things you
know really yeah unless you're on stage
then you're like sure cuz you're in
complete control yeah well like if you
if you get a laugh on something you know
like okay well that this thing has been
can confirmed or reaffirmed something
you thought about reality something you
thought about yourself or whatever is
being confirmed and that feels good but
when you're when you're thinking about
things when you're talking about things
with people there's yeah there's much
more doubt for me you know it's well
it's so much more open-ended
well I do I like I really do say I don't
know about a lot of things because I'll
put it out there and I'll go yeah but
you just say it with affirmation but but
I don't really know yeah I don't know
what is maybe your most epic bomb like I
can imagine you're you have like your
comedy is this very high concept not
imagine starting here in st. Louis and
then travelling around there's got a
their house they're gonna show that like
it just everybody oh you know we
realized a lot I could pick many is
there well it's funny like when I like
starting in Missouri there's just
driving around over all these years like
I can pass almost every exit on the
highway and go like Oh had a bad show
over there like all these towns you know
that did their little one night of
comedy and I came in and it yeah so but
I mean I suppose the worst was probably
this place called Sullivan Missouri
it was Pirates place was the name of the
venue they were doing comedy for a
little bit they can't I came in to
feature and yeah people were upset but
then the the guy who was booking it
didn't really understand how anything
worked in then he booked me to headline
like two months later so then I come
back and do 12 twice as long and then
you know walked a lot of the crowd but
one woman in particular she she stood up
and she and she said I rebuke you Satan
to me she rebuked me so yeah how long
into your set
yeah maybe 20 minutes yeah out of a
headlining set yeah so like you guy dude
45 and yeah I did the 45 less than
halfway through a lady stands up and
goes I rebuke you say Satan yeah do you
remember the joke that triggered it yeah
yeah people are coming in is that Satan
coming in right now what uh so you
finished the set though the first ascent
yeah I always finish the set although
one said I wasn't able to finish it was
the day after Trump got elected it was
November 9th 2016 Dodge City Kansas I
got kicked off of a stage by a the owner
of the bar
I was doing a 30-minute set he he threw
me off at like minute 28 oh you're
making like Trump jokes no Trump jokes
no just like it's all like religion yeah
I was science science religion
philosophy some stuff about the
military-industrial complex you know
when when the lady says I rebuke you say
yeah
what is your retort well I don't know I
mean it really caught me off guard
I mean I guess I just laughed at a
continued I understand her position I
really do and then I you know wrote a
joke about it later but not in the
moment no so so people are walking oh
yeah oh less than 20 mancine your set
people are getting up and walking out
yeah and then a 20-minute 20 she stands
up I rebuke you Satan yeah and then you
just keep going do more people keep
leaving the Schiele yeah be like yeah
people are just up and around but I'm
doing my set you know oh my gosh how
long in the comedy was this um maybe
2015 yeah so yeah four years ago yeah I
rebuke you Satan yeah that's a new
heckle I've never heard someone say they
got heckled like that yeah yeah at my I
mean it happens all the time
I did a jfl showcase audition in Seattle
and right in the middle of it someone
said you're going to help hood up and
said you're going to hell she got get
down in Seattle yeah
whoa but this part of that mean there's
that part of it
when you get those kind of reactions
does it make you feel like oh well this
is this materials affecting people
emotionally so I'm on the right track
the intended effect you know you are
after both yeah absolutely but it is
funny it's like the yeah the intent is
not to offend but it's funny you do the
material so much and like it's a mix you
do it so much and then you forget like
oh it this does affect people this it's
not entirely benign you know like there
is some power or some influence that you
have with your act you know
so but there's there's a bravery behind
it and I think that's why so many people
care about you and I really I mean it
really was like going around the st.
Louis comedy scene I mean and I'm not
I'm not trying to fluff your feathers
but I mean like comedians really there
was like a sincerity and like a major
respect around you and there was there
was like a heartfelt connection it seems
at least the comedians were having
around you end this show I mean the show
us all you do you killed as well so the
material works but what do you what do
you attribute to the influence you're
having just amongst comedians I just I'm
around a lot so um and people have seen
the different sort of stages of my
career and yeah I really try to give
people time and yet give them their
dignity every comic at every level you
know I've talked to a lot of new comics
about comedy theory and they just asked
me a lot of questions about the art and
about sort of going out on the road and
how do you do this and and I give all
the information I can mm-hmm because I
understand exactly what their position
is you know and yeah no one's teaching
you how to do this you got to go ask
some questions so yep I'm happy to
answer anything that anyone asks you
know well I can guarantee people are
gonna be reach out to the hot breath
averse is strong they reach out to
guests and they get it done yeah cool so
that's why I wanted you on here because
comedians there's a great like there's
an there was an orbit around you in a
sense where comedians just they wanted
to be around you and they respect you
and you got me on this open mic that was
already full of 30 comics and the guy
was still like yeah we'll put them up
and we'll put them up early so we don't
have to sit through this tragedy that is
a show yeah
so there's just in me knowing and being
in Atlanta like and seeing a comedy
scene and it growing and different
players within it it's just cool to
you'reyou're an important piece of this
comedy scene and you attribute that to
just being nice and around I guess just
carrying a lot of you know the herring
caring about comedy and taking it
seriously mm-hmm
yeah really pushing myself and pushing
other people so yeah I've challenged a
lot of comedians to to be better you
know we should all be better we should
yeah you know and it's cool you're
challenging yourself I mean you it's
easy for a comic to get get in the
position you are here in st. Louis and
just get comfortable and just be like oh
well I have a tribe here in a sense but
you moved to Chicago and then you moved
to see a kind if I moved to Chicago I
was like basic I was living in an air
B&B for like yeah probably six months I
was like an it was basically a hostel I
was like sleeping in bunk beds I've
slept in a lot of bunk beds that's one
of the keys to DIY comedy you gotta go
like really be comfortable with like
sleeping either above or below a lot of
people that's that's what's funny I love
the the DIY comedy I just interviewed a
comic here at the festival who lives in
his van and we did a tour of his van and
he's showing me like he unfolds his
toilet he's like for emergencies this is
where I'll poop and it's like all of
this and he's like an here's my handheld
heater for when it's freezing and you're
like oh that's cool we lived in a van
and then you hear the reality and it's
like you yeah like oh he's really doing
it and then you're like he's sleeping in
a hostel like oh yeah a shady situation
but tell us more about that DIY reality
yeah I mean like in terms of the
standard of living yeah I think you
really got to be okay with couches and
floors and you kind of have to get by on
the generosity of other people I've I've
toured this country a lot and people
have let me stay with them and they've
fed me and yeah people have it's amazing
what people will do if they get to know
you and if they think you're funny and
yeah people want to help you along it's
really cool so that's one thing and when
it comes to DIY comedy it's you just
always have to be looking for your own
opportunities you really have to sort of
like be planning ahead like where it's
like you really have to go like well
what would I like to do and then you try
to figure out the puzzle you go how can
I make this happen and not wait for
anybody else to do it for me you know I
know that's sort of sort of vague but
like I have having sure
certain festivals or certain
destinations or certain venues and you
just got a yeah I don't know it's sort
of like this I grew up playing like
Zelda right on n64 ocarina of time and I
think it's that's a good model for like
it's a good simulation where you're like
this little kid running around in this
open world in this game right and you go
to all these new lands and you have you
don't just get you don't just go and
fight people you have to go up to the
people in the town and app you press a
you ask them a question and you learn
things and you piece that together so
you figure out how to get to them to the
boss that you fight do you know what I
mean mm-hmm and that's how light life is
there's all these people they all have
information they all have all this
knowledge from experience go out and and
learn from them and piece things
together you know and figure out where
to go yeah so yeah that's my journey
with this podcast absolutely sitting
down we're clicking a over and over
again every Monday I'm clicking it yeah
and every Monday listeners are clicking
a I would say that's a that's a great
very clear analogy yeah Wow but you have
to go up and do that you know you have
to yeah you have to the or you're just
running around you know throwing the
rocks or like doing your sword at those
chickens in the game right go up to the
people that live in the town and ask
them the questions and you'll know your
questions when you know your destination
yeah because I do think that's important
you're like we need to know first what
you want to do yeah where is the finish
line and then you can work backwards to
build finish line is dad there oh do we
what happens when we die yeah nothing
you think nothing happens when we die
well something happens you know for sure
but yeah I think basically like yeah
your your consciousness is no longer it
activated because it seems to be
contained in the your brain mm-hmm and
then all of life continues to go so so
you're here you're alive for a while and
then you die and then the entire system
of life continues to go you know without
you yeah
that's how we're gonna end this no we're
not gonna end it on that no let's let's
let's circle back to a positive yeah the
device I think that's positive oh they
know that you died peacefully well know
that like there's no such thing as like
ultimate death it's just you like if
you'd let go of the purse the individual
ego or it's like yeah life's life it's
not about you life it's not there's a
whole system going yeah and you're here
to experience that and then it continues
to go and then you're no you're no
longer here and that's so like every
life just keeps flowing and flowing and
flowing and death seems to be quite up
you know part of that death seems to be
the thing that like sort of propels life
it's it's the balance it's the the the
yin to the yang but a more positive
death sounds like being in the clouds
eating marshmallows with angels sounds
more positive than oh yeah life goes on
without you I disagree
yeah I you know like marshmallows yeah I
think I think it's I don't think it's
it's negative at all that that the
universe continues to evolve and
continues to make life you know it
inspires you to make the most of your
opportunity as well though yeah so if
you're like this is my shot it's like
well no one else is gonna give me a shot
let me create my own shot like you're
doing and a lot of that you said is
asking questions it is learning so even
making the decision not because I've had
people reach out to me I had a guy
recently reach out to me from New Jersey
who was like I'm trying to sign if I
want to move to New York or Atlanta to
pursue their commie in a more serious
like fashion so you moving to Chicago
moving up being a vagrant of some sort I
guess what was that decision make like
why did you decide to do that I just
thought there are more opportunities
there there's free call for calm call
for comedy okay really almost everything
I've done in my life has been for for a
comedy yeah yeah that's the reality of
there but it's because I love it it's
it's important I love right so it's not
it's not just comedy it's sort of the
experience of love so yeah but I moved I
moved there for comedy there's so much
going on there's so many great comedians
and I learned a lot and got a lot better
and then decided to go to the Pacific
Northwest because I really enjoyed it up
there but we got to meet each other yeah
we did meet each other if you didn't go
to Chicago we wouldn't be here right now
well we would yeah I guess we wouldn't
have met each other yeah and then we
wouldn't have randomly seen each other
here and been like a Chicago yeah and
you want to go do this oppa Mike yeah
you know yeah so what it never happened
hmm maybe maybe maybe I like you more
than you like me maybe that's a I don't
know it was cool you know we don't just
let anyone on this show Andrew this I
look at the list today and it's you got
a good list and now you're on it yeah so
listen to Joe lists episode yeah looked
at the list and then pick Joe list then
yeah yeah he's a he's a good egg as they
say yeah so you moved to Chicago and
then like we said Seattle why did you
leave Chicago to Seattle what was the
the plan behind that well I had been up
there for the Seattle International
Comedy Competition in 2017 and I just
really enjoyed the scene there I liked
the nature I really wanted to be in a
city that stimulated me the environment
and stimulated stimulated me so being in
a major metropolis is hard for my mental
health so being around a bunch of trees
being able to I mean I live I live in
Green Lake in Seattle so I can its point
two miles to the club so I walked to the
club and point two miles from there is
ravenna Park which is like you can hike
and it's like this awesome Valley is a
huge huge trees and then there's a giant
lake right by my place so yeah to have
the to have both an enough
to support the arts and then to also
have nature to be surrounded by water to
be surrounded by trees it was very
important to me and to be close to
Canada I really enjoy performing in
Canada okay yeah it just seems like as a
comedian it seems most comedians would
be like okay I moved to this bigger city
to get better now it's time for LA or
New York but you decide you know I went
to Seattle because I like the
environment
sure well I'm gonna be travelling
anywhere like basically the way I do
things as I'll live somewhere for half
the year and I travel the rest of the
year so I've been away from Seattle for
the last three months I went yeah so
yeah we're all did you go well I started
in Seattle Argo went to Chicago
Pittsburgh Washington DC in New York
City London Edinburgh Glasgow and then
st. Louis Vancouver Springfield now I'm
back and then one more week at
Springfield then I go back to Seattle
yeah oh and you booked all of this how
cuz I I just I just booked my first tour
here in October and I'm going to the
southeast and like every date is really
thanks to a listener like every day that
booked was yeah people who are fans of
the podcast so how how were you able to
book such a long run of shows like that
well two of the major stretches were
fringe festivals 25 shows in Edinburgh
for the whole month of August that was
that fringe and then Vancouver was ten
shows and you just you send a video to
these guys they offer you a venue and a
time slot and the new sort of sorted out
from there the other shows or just I
don't know like everything sort of
snowballs if you really travel around
enough if you really do enough shows if
you're getting onstage all the time and
you keep doing festivals and keep going
to clubs keep doing contests and stuff
you just end up meeting so many people
in so many different places and you can
either reach out to them or like I would
say seventy percent of the time people
reach out to me and say like hey when
are you gonna be around and we just and
then you just piece together the puzzle
you know once you have a couple things
on a calendar then now you just look at
a map and you figure it out from there
you know yeah and you probably did with
your tour you figured out a couple
cities and then you're like
what's around here exactly and that's
the beauty of we're in a real comedy
boom right now every every city every
town that has some people has a scene
going on has regular shows and yeah if
you're nice enough and if you and if you
have enough of a resume and you got a
good video and people know who you are
then you can hop on shows you know and
just being a nice person yeah like you
said first off just being generous being
caring and being someone people want to
work with sure yeah offer your show and
and the other thing is just sort of like
over the years if you it's funny people
always ask me like you know how do you
start working at clubs in other cities
and I it's it's a long game right but it
really is the same way that you get in
in your local scene it's just greater
distances so like yeah you just you get
in your car and you go to these places
you find the right times to go and you
keep returning to them year after year
after year after year and they see your
growth they see your improvement and
then you yeah you get some work but it's
it's the same same thing with you you
just have to keep going it's you don't
just show up someplace once and then
they give everything to you you have to
build a relationship with venues and
Booker's and and your peers like like
this festival right there's 200 comics
here and all of these people have
information or may book you on something
so it's it's good to make other comics
laugh and to be do be doing comedy that
has some integrity to it then that other
comics respect you know because then you
get to be on their shows yeah and how
was and thinking of I think it's
important for comics to really remember
is you said keep going back to these
cities but also keep progressing yeah as
well so keep developing keep getting
stronger sure keep putting the work
onstage as much as you are off stage
absolutely yeah yeah it's important yeah
because it and it really yeah you grow
so much in comedy even in just in a year
right the difference you can if you
really put in the work people are gonna
notice they may not notice as much in
your local scene because they see you
all the time right so if you go back to
a club and you haven't
there in a year and they see what you're
doing now it's it's very cool so yeah I
was just recently in Chattanooga at the
comedy catch for the second time and
someone who someone saw me there the
first time and I saw me to have a second
time and they like send me an email
about how much I had like developed in
just the six or seven months since I was
their last and that was really that that
was probably my first experience of like
oh okay because I I can't get insulin in
Atlanta and I'm getting out more clearly
with this tour and I'm planning one in
the Midwest now for the neck for next
month but it's like when you get out you
can I think leaving your scene is
healthy because then you do start to see
your come in a different way and you
start to see how other people are doing
comedy right because right I know we get
on stage independently but you're seeing
you're all sort of like learning the
language of comedy together and you may
be learning to speak the same way to
think the same way and you got to get
out there on your own let's see what
other people are doing and yeah I think
just that's like sort of the hero's
journey of it all like when you when you
go to another place and you come back
like and you and you spend real time
alone this is a major part of stand-up
you gotta spend those hours alone
getting to and from places yeah you
really sort of develop yourself and and
sort of like earlier you were saying
like this you said this style of comedy
is like brave or something but it really
it's just a matter of like it's not
really worth it in the grand scheme of
things if you really are gonna sacrifice
all these things in in your life to
really pursue this comedy thing fully
you know sleeping in the hostel and
spending time away from people you love
and yeah make it matter like create
something that really means something to
you and don't don't pander and don't do
it just for the crowd because they don't
get in the car with you and drive to the
next place they don't do you know what I
mean like you got to live with yourself
and you got to do something that you're
proud of you know
because well and the worst-case scenario
is and everyone learns to server the
years but like if you'd do what you
think they want a new pander and it
still doesn't work then you've sold
yourself for nothing right and I'm gonna
drive ten hours back to you know from
Dodge City Kansas and you're like why
did I do that you know so so yeah to be
to create something that you're proud of
something that you that you want to
present to people and that yeah so so
where where are you at now
so you're 12 years in you've done all
these tours you just went to I mean Eden
Edinboro Edinburgh what is Edinburgh
Edinburgh Fringe Festival that the
biggest Arts fest on the world yeah
that's what I'm saying like that's
that's like a that's like a mecca that's
a destination yeah so many levels to it
so I started at the at the bottom level
of it and you could I could keep going
back for a lifetime and continue to
climb yeah like we like you said in
getting in with a scene you just got to
show up first no maybe it's like a guest
spot and the next time you may only make
it like you may be hosting or whatever
but in Edinburgh you were doing an hour
yep every night for 30 days right 25
days for 25 days was what did you learn
from that experience and also was the
audience more receptive were they kind
of more hip to your style yeah they were
very good crowds I learned a lot I I
think basically through that repetition
I just you just really start to
understand the nuances of your material
and you really sort of develop that
skill of yeah doing the same jokes every
night and doing them in a way that feels
alive you know like doing yeah really
it's hard to explain but it's like it's
not you're not just reciting material
you have to be very sensitive to the way
you're presenting it to people and yes
so the material just got a lot more
nuanced and and conversational and the
laughs definitely multiplied you know
you find you find all these new spots
that you get laughs and in these ideas
and that ideas grow and so yeah that's
the it's the being a
observed thing if you really keep
continue if you continue to be observed
this and you're honest with yourself and
you really are aware the stuff is going
to continue to improve we're and we you
had referenced earlier knowing where you
want to be and then kind of working
backwards so where what are you working
towards now where do you want to be I
would like to continue to tour like
really ideally I would do an American
tour Canadian tour Europe UK Europe tour
and an Australian tour every year I
would like to do that I'm close to that
I did I did
Europe America Canada this year so and
the people that ran the the venue in
Edinburgh which I knew this ahead of
time it's all part of the plan they run
things at the Adelaide Fringe Festival
the Melbourne International Comedy
Festival and the Perth Festival so I
would like to spend three months in
Australia next year the year after that
probably not next year to be honest I
would like to write another act to be
honest I
I would like to wait until I have
another hour or yeah something like that
but some yeah I would like to that's one
thing and just continuing to up the
quality of the venues and the and the
opportunities so yeah jfl is something
that I would like soon there's many
steps to that so I got the first first
showcase first audition for that in
January when I moved up to Seattle and
then I think you just got to keep keep
like so they have now they have an
impression of me you keep doing it year
after year and hopefully show them your
growth you know that's one thing yeah
but really I just want the material to
get better I want to be a better
comedian and perform a new and better
places and see where that takes me are
these fringe festivals more like kind of
one-man show II as opposed to like a
stand-up like is your is the hour your
building like you said you want a new
hour before you go to Oslo you're like
is the hour almost like us like it has
like a story are more than just like
here's a set exactly what I would do in
a club it's exactly my act oh okay cool
and it's jokes the whole time for an
hour
but thematically it is it fits in with
the with the festival vibe ah okay but
it's straight stand-up you know but
that's the thing stand up can do a lot
of things like you really can say things
that are emotional you can say things
that are intellectual all that stuff can
be contained in in comedy you know yeah
I think it's important for comics to
look at their stand-up as like a show
like you're saying because when I taped
my my special and that's my first time
ever putting putting myself on the like
on the fire like that I'm like okay you
have a date and you have to nail this is
like I had a lot of material but as I
started to mold it together I was like
oh but that joke actually ties to this
joke and it became yeah just organically
through the trial and error it actually
became like a story and the biggest
compliment was oh wait it had like an
arc to it sure and before I put that
pressure on myself to create a show I
was more like oh I just have all this
material about my life but as I started
to mold together it was like oh it's
there's a story and I can take him down
here because I like I cried at my
wedding
yeah and a big part of me talking about
it I wanted to actually cry when I
talked about I wanted to go to that
moment and actually cry and then flip it
the punchline like misdirecting that I
wasn't crying I was crying that the
wedding planning was over but I build up
to that moment
so part documenting the special we show
the the evolution of that joke for me in
an open mic to where I'm like trying to
fake cry I'm all the way to the
progression of it at the special where I
do hit that note and and it gets an
applause break huh that's the first time
I think it's important for comics to
challenge themselves in that way to of
like how far can i push to perform its
aspect of my show absolutely because
that was in nine and a half years that
was my first time like oh I want to take
him down for a minute yeah oh but this
is gonna I need to work at that moment
and when I nailed it and got an applause
break I was like oh it's there like you
said stand-up can do so many things
that's that's that resonated with me
begin inspired that story because that
was my first moment on stage
I was like oh there's more to this than
just like yeah I can take them down and
around and really affect them sure yeah
so like emotions and vulnerability and
honesty these things are so important
for comedy like yeah I see a lot of
comics who like are like irony is their
main sort of mode of expression and I
and as cool as that is and it's like
there's great jokes that can be told I
do think you hit a wall I think it's a
defense mechanism and it's sort of like
you put up a wall between you don't want
the crowd to see your real self what you
really feel I mean really think and so
we create a character for the stage as
opposed to so so anyway so you having
those emotions and you're really talking
about it and making a joke of it but
yeah like I don't know a lot of comedy
can be very detached and I think it's
important to it's really show who you
are up there agreed agreed and I always
try to put my material through the
filter of could someone else say this
and then be just as funny mm-hmm you
know like how can I make this material
uniquely mine and that takes time you
know I'm nine and a half years in your
12 years so this all takes time and
people listeners need to understand that
but I think the sooner you can make that
your intent with your comedy the sooner
you're gonna start to see that progress
and start making that connection with an
audience where it is I rebuke you Satan
or they're coming up after like telling
you not just saying you were funny but
like telling you what was funny and why
and how it affected them that's changed
my whole approach to comedy when people
started coming up after and really like
explaining how they were affected as
opposed to you were funny I don't
remember anything you said yeah you were
funny
yeah I'm like I do think and you can
stand up like if you tore enough you're
in a lot of new places and you don't
really stay for very long so that and
you want D like deep human connection
right so there is something it's very
intentional the act that I present it's
an out like the Edinboro was so nice
because all these people sort of came up
and we're already like an hour into a
conversation and they know who I am and
what I think about the world and then
they
tell me their ideas and they tell me
their experiences with these things and
it sort of encourages this type of
conversation and this type of connection
that is as very hard to create so yeah I
think like that's been a very life
sustaining thing is like you you go on
stage and you like you connect with
people in a certain way and then like
they have the quality of the
conversation and what people are willing
to tell you about themselves outwards as
much higher after you you've shared
about yourself you know because everyone
sort of hides a bunch of stuff you know
yeah of course huh so yeah the fact that
someone would would know that they're
that they're safe and that they won't be
judged and that that they can talk to
another person about things that they've
thought about our experience that's very
cool you know yeah you end up making
some really really close friends and
have the all these awesome relationships
in a very short amount of time when
you're on the road you know and then you
go back and you continue to see those
people so do you collect these people's
emails or do you anything do you do
anything to stay in touch with them even
when you're not sure like yes behind the
tour in a sense you know what I mean
like it's cool to go on tour but like
how do you live because like I mean for
instance you know I mean it's I have a
recent experience I was in like when I
travel I mean even here you know I just
baked a bunch of sweet potatoes and
boiled eggs I was in Birmingham recently
the fridge was too cold the eggs were
frozen I'm sitting here eating crunchy
eggs and a hotel alone so like what is
your experience with the reality of that
DIY approach like yeah I'm doing it and
then sometimes you're like oh I'm doing
anything weird of course yeah yeah I
hate haggis and Edinburgh do you know
what haggis is I've heard the word I
it's like a sheep intestines oh okay but
that's like a delicacy there I guess so
yeah it's not like Vienna sausages yeah
it's not that depressing I guess but I
don't know like yeah I eat a lot of
weird things just on the road though you
know what I mean like just to get by and
mmm yeah it's all like a game you know
it's all a game
keep yourself alive and keep telling
jokes all icky yeah it's a fun game
though ya know yeah when you really have
something that you love and really
something that's motivating you it makes
everything a lot easier you know and
ether of thing that you like any
obstacle or any sort of I don't know
your car breaks down or like you know
you don't have a place to stay or all
these things like it's it's all like
these are just sort of like obstacles
that are I don't you just figure it out
like I sort of like the challenge of it
all I like yeah I like their survival
aspect of it you know yeah
life finds a way yeah as Jeff Goldblum
says in Jurassic Park and I get like and
there makes a lot easier if you just
love if you love people you know yeah
yeah cuz then though you know
it'll all be alright it makes me when
you're when you're doing what you love
it makes all the work worth it too so
it's like if you are having to sleep in
your car because you couldn't find a
place it is like what I'm I would rather
be doing this then waking up to go to a
cubicle tomorrow sure you know yeah I
think like sort of owning your own like
labor as if it's yeah that's yeah it's
something I really think is important
and not everybody can do it is and it
does take a long time to get to that
point but um yeah to like to have a
skill that belongs to you and that you
can it contributes value to other people
and you can yeah to own your own labour
is very important to me woo
dude this has been maybe the fastest
interviews gone we're at an hour okay um
this is probably the fastest iPhotos
episode is flown by because like I
usually I mean have like a whole list
sure I mean I have this whole pager
research and like I die I like private
investigate my guests almost to the
point of like I know like what hospital
they were born in but like I met you
like yesterday yeah and was just we're
just we're chillin at this open like
afterwards and I was and I'm just like
talking to you for all these hours I was
like dude you should do that you should
be doing that you should do the podcast
we should have been doing it this whole
time like
just there's something about you so it
compelled me to do this and I think I
learned a lot from this experience and
just I didn't have all these talking
points so it it challenged me to listen
more intently so and it allowed me to be
more in the moment and just react more
and I feel like I'm gonna carry that
forward and I don't know why I felt
compelled to tell you that right now
as if you you've changed you feel that
way yeah yeah I don't know we should all
be getting the best out of each other
that's a good point and when you when
you're finding the best in yourself it
there must be some sort of unseen
connection that inspires you to do the
same because I don't know what just ran
into you and then we go to these open
mics and I'm like this guy's amazing he
needs to be on here yeah how what is the
sauce you know so I appreciate you
taking the time to do this it's um it's
been very fun it's this is one of those
moments in comedy that like I think is
like it's one of those tipping points of
like okay time there's like a new
chapter to start writing what's the new
chapter the the self-made approach I
think and like you said creating that
connection and owning your labor like up
till now really it's been more of just
like I just want to get good at stand-up
and then just be on stage and just be
cool or what to us to a degree you know
but actually thinking of the further
impact you can have with your comedy and
just what you can do on your own and I'm
on your own I mean putting in the work
and labor but you can't create a tour
alone you know being loving people yeah
you always get other people yes have you
ever seen inside Llewyn Davis the
brother maybe yes it's one of my
favorite movies and one of the main sort
of lessons that like Lewin is you know
there's traveling like or he's he's a
folk musician in the granite and
Greenwich Village in the 60s and he he's
in this sort of like creative purgatory
where he's incredibly talented but he's
like sort of an [__] and he like
doesn't really treat people well and
he's is stuck in this cycle right
can't ever met he can't ever get more
success and no one ever notices him and
he sort of fails to appreciate all the
people that are taking care of him
and that he he's you can't be
narcissistic in this you can't or you
you can't think that this is all about
you there's all these people that are
involved in your life and that are part
of your journey and it's your even if
you're up there with your guitar alone
even if you're telling jokes you know
individually you're connected to all the
other people and every crowd every
person you stay with every person that
you talk to you like and these ideas
aren't coming from you alone like you
went to a school and you had a family
and like all these friends and all these
people so yeah we should help try to be
as sort of original and creative as we
can be but let's let's be honest here
all like we're all influencing each
other and all its sharing knowledge and
experience with each other so yeah it's
really appreciate that and yeah it's to
be grateful for the other people in your
life you know and to know that they like
they've created you just as much as as
you've created yourself yes especially
your parents yeah do create you yeah see
we came full circle there so you've been
so generous with an information and
insight before we get out of here is
there anything else you want the world
to know where you want comedians advice
or is there anything else you want to
leave us with no no no great I guess not
okay you said a lot yeah I always
pleased with it oh I love this okay oh
this has been one of my favorite
episodes for sure done almost 200 years
this is one of my favorites so I learned
a lot from you and I know the listeners
did but always close the interviews by
asking the guest is there anything else
they want the world to know and some
people just say no and some people then
add another 20-minute diatribe you know
so I'm sort of under the I'm sort of in
the camp where it's like whoever wants
to know stuff they're gonna go for like
curiosity is the thing that should
inform it so we can tell each other
things but ultimately the sort of the
chin and the search has to come from
from you do you know I mean so does that
make sense like so yeah you can't really
like tell people things they sort of
have to want to know mmm right Mike draw
whatever you whatever you want to know
go go and it's and don't think you just
get to figure it out like
instantaneously it's a long thing it's a
process yeah and it's work but it's
worth it yeah so please please let the
hot breath of ours know where they can
connect with you sure and support you
and like you said you like answering
questions I love it yeah how can they
connect with you you could email me
directly and Andrew Frank comedy at
gmail.com I have a Facebook a personal
Facebook page hold on us yeah you're
good we want to reset okay that's fine
no I mean we're gonna leave it in but I
just want I want to make sure they hear
how I can connect with you yeah
Andrew Frank comedy at gmail.com is my
my email I answer all my emails I have a
personal Facebook page Andrew Frank I
have a fan page but I don't do anything
on it so I just sort of speak to people
more directly so people can add me there
and and my website is handy Frank comedy
comm I have a bunch of stuff on YouTube
as well I have I have an hour that I
filmed here in st. Louis in 2016 it's
just on YouTube
it's called Andrew Frank macrocosm great
name yeah and yeah I filmed that when I
was 23 it's it's good this stuff is
better now and but it's it's up there
mm-hm there's a bunch of showcase videos
and stuff so yeah you can find me there
and you can look at my schedule and just
see me live somewhere and we'll talk you
know awesome Hey
and you Frank Thank You Man did you have
fun would you would you mind look into
the camera and tell people why they
should listen to hot breath why they
should yeah let them know who you are
and why they should listen to hot breath
hi I'm Andrew Frank and if you're a
comedian or anybody interested in comedy
this is a thing to listen to that is
lovely and informative and joel's
awesome
and I think you can get a lot out of it
and it'll make your day better it will
get you to where you're going if you're
listening to this in the car or you're
walking so hopefully you're walking
somewhere for the for the sake of the
planet but yeah they'll get you to your
destination it'll get you somewhere in
your mind that is a good place to go so
check it out check out all the episodes
hi Brad you didn't you nailed it all
right Andrew Frank that is all we'll see
you next Monday how breath averse hi
everybody
[Music]
I breath